-Our next guest is
an award-winning chef
and founder of
Milk Bar Bakeries.
She's one of our favorites.
She has a new book out called
"Dessert Can Save the World."
Please welcome Chef Christina
Tosi, ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now!
Welcome back. We love you.
Welcome, welcome back.
This is your first memoir.
-It is.
I just felt like it was
an important message
when I was writing it,
and it continues to remind me
now that it's out that
it's like a rally call.
It's a reminder that we need
joy, that joy matters,
that knowing ourselves, finding
these moments that connect us
to ourselves, to other people,
to the world,
these are like the connective
tissues that make life worth
living and fighting for and like
just being good and doing good.
That's what the book's
all about.
-There's little things in here
that make me laugh.
There's things called
"dirty dessert secrets."
-Mm-hmm.
-Can you explain what those are?
-Yes, I can.
-Thank you.
-The things, for me,
my dirty dessert secrets
are all like pantry-loading,
right?
Like, it's late at night,
no one's home.
I had a day, I need a moment.
So I brought for you some of my
favorite dirty dessert secrets.
I have hot cocoa mix
and maple syrup.
You mix it until it becomes like
a fudgy consistency.
Get in there.
I'm gonna spoon some for Quest.
You can just have
a little nibble.
Look at this. Also, I forgot
to tell you number-one rule of
dirty dessert secrets --
no judgment.
-Okay.
-This is a judgment-free zone.
-But this is maple syrup
and hot cocoa mix.
Wow.
-You're not mad at it, are you?
-How'd you do that?
-You're not mad at it.
-I'm not mad at all.
-Mm-hmm.
You ready for the next one?
-I love that. Yes.
-M&Ms.
You pour hot water over them.
You strain them out like this.
-Whoa!
-Very, very strange color.
You mash them around
with a spoon
and then you eat them.
Take a little spoonful.
-It's fantastic.
-Oh, yo!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right?
This is it.
Okay, you ready for this one?
For me, it, like, brings me
back to high school days.
You take a honey bun.
You warm it up in the microwave.
You mash it down.
-This is one I read in the book.
-You put a Snickers in it.
You roll it up.
Get in there, guys.
-So, it's a honey bun --
-Wrapped around a Snickers.
-Wrapped around a Snickers bar.
-Microwaved.
-And microwaved.
Alright, I'm taking this.
-Tell me. Talk to me.
You mad at it?
-How do you think of this?
-This is, like --
-That is -- That's the winner.
-That's the win-- You aren't
even there yet, though.
-That's the winner right there.
-Okay, you ready for this?
This, for me, is like
church days a little bit.
It's a piece of white bread,
some margarine, and some Tang.
It's called Tang Toast.
-[ Laughs ] Wait, what?
-It's called Tang Toast.
Get in there.
I'm coming right behind you
'cause my next one is coming up.
-Fairy bread.
-Yeah.
-Is your soul feeling lit up
right now?
-Yes, it is. It's from
the honey bun Snickers.
-You first.
-Oh, wow.
-Are you mixing Mountain Dew?
-I'm mixing cake mix
and a can of Mountain Dew.
And then it gets microwaved
5, 10 seconds.
Just go with me. Open mind.
I hear you over there.
Yo, this has been my move.
I'm not kidding.
I had it without Mountain Dew
but with peanut butter and milk
the other night.
This is my always
dirty dessert secret go-to.
You ready for this?
It's a little warm.
It's a little gooey.
Judgment-free zone, guys.
Get in there.
-Mountain Dew --
-His face right now.
-Yeah, yeah. Get in there.
-Mountain Dew and cake mix.
-Your life is
going to be changed.
-Wow.
-This is just -- This is what
Milk Bar was built on, guys.
-How did you think of this?
-No way, the best one
is yet to come.
But this is a real trust fall,
okay?
-Okay.
-Judgment-free zone.
It's not about how we portray
ourselves to the outside world.
It's about what happens
when no one's looking.
-Just do it.
-You ready for this?
You guys got to close your eyes.
I got you --
I got you some masks.
Quest, that's for you.
-I don't know.
-Jims, this is for you.
-I don't know anything about it.
-Okay.
-Just trust me. Trust me.
-We always do.
-Yeah. I believe in you guys.
Okay.
-Can you see anything?
-I'm going to give you something
and each of you just pinch this.
Yep. Just hold it like that.
I'm going to give you something
to dunk it in.
Okay, there we go.
No peeking yet. No peeking yet.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Wait, why's the audience --
-I know. The audience is ewwing.
-It's 'cause they're jealous.
It's 'cause they're jealous.
Okay, give me a dunk.
Dunk but dunk like a big dunk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, not yet, Jimmy.
-Like this?
-Is that your arm?
-That's my arm. Okay, hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Love your perfume.
-Can I dunk it?
A big dunk. You got it,
but no, come back in,
a bigger dunk, Jimmy.
Okay.
-Yeah.
-Did I dunk it?
Get in there, one, two, three.
-So consume this?
-Bottoms up. Consume.
Do it, do it.
Okay, you want to know
what you just had?
Okay. Masks off, guys.
Flaming hot Cheetos,
vanilla frosting.
This is the ultimate
dirty dessert secret.
-Yeah, I dig it, too.
-[ Laughs ]
-You are a genius. How do you
come up with this stuff?
We love you.
Christina Tosi, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dessert Can Save the World"
is out now.